[Music]
an Oklahoma father carried out an
elaborate sting to catch an alleged
sexual predator he said the man was
targeting his 15 year old daughter
police said Jeremy Dewayne Gibson
pursued the girl online and went to her
home to have sex with her but when he
arrived her family tackled him and took
him to the ground
david beg no spoke with the girl's
father in Del City that's a suburb of
Oklahoma City David good morning
hey David good morning it happened in
this backyard the family had it all set
up the pot the father put this tent as a
decoy he had that camera right there
that was rolling so it would capture the
moment the man walked into the backyard
earlier that day the dad had gone to
police filed a police report and said
hey here are the messages explicit
messages this man is exchanging with my
daughter but then he got word that the
man was apparently coming to the family
home that night so he thought well I got
to do something so he got his wife and a
few of his cousins and he set up a
family sting operation when Jeremy
Dewayne Gibson arrived to this home
around 12:30 last Thursday morning he
probably didn't expect this surprise he
was tackled to the ground by three men
his hands and feet bound with zip ties
the teenage girl he allegedly thought
was in that tent turned out to be a
grown woman did you have any trepidation
that somebody might get hurt in all this
the thought did cross my mind yes very
much so but the the situation outweighed
those thoughts the father who asked us
not to reveal his name says Gibson
recently began sending Facebook messages
and nude pictures to his daughter do you
think he knew she was 15 yes yes I do
you think your daughter understands what
she was opening herself up to I don't
think she did I do think she doesn't
know the dad says he was tipped off to
his daughters online chats through an
app that he was using called family time
that enabled him to monitor his daughter
cell phone he was messaging her and
encouraging her to meet him kind of
setting up a situation to where she
would lose her virginity with him so
this dad filed a police report but later
that day he saw messages indicating
Gibson was meeting his daughter at the
family's house that night so he hatched
the plan essentially you made a
citizen's arrest
correct what'd you tell him I told him
that he stepped into the wrong backyard
and he messed with the wrong little girl
police charged Gibson with one
of using technology to engage in sexual
communication with a minor they did it
without harming him or leaving any
bruises or marks on him
major Jodi suit with the Dell City
Police Department says the family
operation was quote almost professional
but we'd never encouraged people to take
the law into their own hands that's what
we're paid to take risk for if I wasn't
as involved as I am I I don't know when
I would have caught this and that scares
me not just for my children and my
family but for other children and other
families out there Jeremy Gibson is out
of jail this morning he bonded out we
sent a producer to his house no one was
home and we called him but we couldn't
reach him it's worth noting the suspect
apparently told police he was coming
here and going to that tent to show the
girl the error of her ways scale the
father doesn't believe that but I do
want you to know the dad said I wasn't
trying to hurt this guy in fact once
they tackled him he gave up he said
listen that's it the dad said I just
wanted to stop him and then turn him
over to police you know who else doesn't
believe mr. Gibson anybody listening to
you talk right now it's over the Airways
okay how creepy is that thank you David
maybe is it that you're going to her
house knowing she's gonna be in a tent
and knowing that she's 15 go dad yeah I
like that dad I like family time apt to
yeah nicely done
again please say do not try that yeah
but it worked that time